what's your level of tolerance for um
pushback and um drama you know when it
comes to women today
comply or goodbye it's a it's super
simple
that's it man i don't have to because i
can't even answer all the messages in my
inbox anyway
you just use like the standard line like
you know i don't date women that insert
you know negative behavior
i'll you know i'll do it
conversationally i'm not a complete
jackass about it that's another thing i
think guys get wrong they think that
they they're going to come through and
and
jump off the top rope if you will
you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah
you're not the [ __ ] rock okay so calm
down no so it's very subtle it's like
yeah you know i'll bring it up in
conversation it's like you know if i get
serious about chick you know i don't i
don't do guy friends you know and i'll
give them the whole lamborghini and the
hood thing or or whatever it and not and
i'll you know i'll tell them or if they
do something like like you know
go on a boat or something hey listen no
disrespect i thought we were more
serious than that or you know our i
thought you took us more serious than
that you know i i can't take you
seriously if if we're gonna have sex and
you're gonna go on the boat two days
later in miami yeah i don't i'm not
trying to tell you what to do you do
what you want with your life i'm just
letting you know that i don't do that
you know so it's it's very
it's very um
it's very much less what you think it
would be a lot of uh justin oh you're
just controlling you're insecure like
how do you deal with those lyrics
no i i don't get a whole lot of that but
if if a woman ever called me insecure i
said no i'm not secure i'm territorial
and if a man doesn't love you enough to
want to be territorial around you and
about you then does he really love you
does he
it's hard it's hard to argue with that
i'm pretty sure i've heard andrew say
that before
yeah i'm sure he has i'm sure he has
um he's he also says the the lamborghini
thing you know about you know leaving
the car parked in the hood yeah yeah i
trust you but i put my car there and i
like to add to that
and what i say is you know the whole
thing is you know i trust the locks on
my lamborghini but i don't i don't park
it in the ghetto and then i asked that
do you use the lamborghini
example when you're dealing with the
girls from louisiana or do you use like
a f-150
yeah i'll probably say my truck truck
you know yeah yeah but um
but what i say to him is so why would
you park it there yeah
because i always want to put it kind of
put it back to her yeah you know
um they inherently know that you're
right you know they just want to see if
if you've got the capacity to keep them
in their place right
it's a test one of the strongest things
that i think a woman can know is that
you can replace her
yeah i've always said like she has to
know that that she's replaceable you
don't need to walk around and and tell
her like [ __ ] you know you're
replaceable it's just she has to know
that she is replaceable
you